يحتوي المقهى الأجنبي في لندن على مجموعة كبيرة من
أكثر من 80 نوعًا مختلفًا من
حبوب البن التي تصطف على الرفوف من كل ركن من أركان
العالم
مثل الهند والسلفادور والبرازيل
على سبيل المثال لا الحصر، هذه القهوة البيروفية هي
قهوة بيروفية عضوية وهي
متوسطة التحميص
ليس هناك صواب أو خطأ عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالقهوة شخصيًا، إذا وجدت
قهوة واستمتعت بها، فالسر
الصحيح هو
التأكد من أن الإسبريسو جيد
وأن الحليب ليس ساخنًا جدًا
[موسيقى]
لاعبة الكريكيت ماريسا وعائلتها  لقد
كنت أدير متاجر القهوة الجزائرية
في لندن سوهو لمدة ثلاثة
أجيال،
كنت أعمل هنا طوال
حياتي على الأرجح منذ أن تمكنت من المشي،
افتتح الكشك أبوابه لأول مرة في عام 1887
وحصل على اسمه من مؤسسه
رجل جزائري هاجر إلى
المملكة المتحدة
تم شراؤها بعد ذلك من قبل
جد ماريسا في الأربعينيات من القرن العشرين، وقد حافظت
شبكتها العالمية لموردي القهوة والشاي
والحلويات على
ازدهار العمل لأكثر من
قرن.
إذا حصلنا على اثنين من الكابتشينو والقهوة السوداء،
يرجى أن
يجتمع عشاق القهوة هنا من جميع أنحاء
العالم ويأتون من أجلها.  أكثر من
مجرد اختيار عالمي،
تقول ماريزا إن مخططات المتجر
المصنوعة من أنواع مختلفة من
الحبوب والتوابل حققت نجاحًا كبيرًا،
فهي مزيج من أفريقيا البرازيلية
وهذه قهوة مشهورة جدًا نستهلكها
ببضع مئات من الكيلوجرامات
تسمح هذه الخلطات أيضًا كل أسبوع للشركة
بتوسيع قاعدة عملائها حتى لو كانوا
على بعد آلاف الأميال وفقًا
للأرقام الصادرة عن منظمة OEC، وهي منصة على الإنترنت تعمل على
تبسيط
بيانات التجارة الدولية.
تم تصدير ما قيمته 346 مليون دولار من القهوة
من المملكة المتحدة في  عام 2020، مما يجعلها
أكبر مصدر للقهوة في المرتبة 23 في
العالم، تقول ماريزا إن فريقها يمكنه
تلقي ما يصل إلى بضع مئات من الطلبات
يوميًا، وقد أرسلناهم إلى العديد من
الأماكن الغريبة، والمكان الذي يبدو
صحيحًا دائمًا هو أننا أرسلناه إلى  رجل نبيل
وكان عنوانه حرفيًا السيد ترتل
بيتش موريشيوس وهذا كل شيء، وقد
وصل إليه أن هذا هو عنوانه ترتل
بيتش
حتى بعد كل هذه السنوات
تظل ماريسا متحمسة لاتباع
خطى جدها،
هذا مثل منزلنا، لا
نفعل ذلك.  'لا أعتبره حتى عملاً، فأنا أراه
كما قلت، غرفة نومي الفوضوية هي
موطن لي
أجنبي